[Applaudissements]
je suis né à 18 ans c'était mai 68
j'ai eu mes premières amours j'ai fait
mes premiers voyages en stop
j'ai quitté mes études quitter mes
parents je suis entré en bohême dans ma
vie j'ai essayé d'être artiste gérard
houllier un peu la guitare le piano
j'ai essayé d' un peu d'être comédien
j'ai fait un peu de cinéma de vidéos
j'ai écrit quelques poèmes la guitare ça
m'a d'ailleurs permis plus tard de
draguer ma future femme en lui jouant
jeux interdits
moi je voulais carrément être victor
hugo godard depardieu miles davis
j'avais mis la barre très haut c'était
ça ou rien mais comme les places étaient
déjà prises
eh ben ça s'est soldé par rien alors
pour compenser cette frustration je me
suis mis à consacrer mon temps à essayer
de mettre en valeur le talent artistique
de mes confrères et consoeurs humain
j'ai comme ça a été organisateur de
spectacles de concerts surtout pendant
une dizaine d'années
c'était à strasbourg dans un café
concert qui s'appelait le café des anges
je me suis aussi occupé d'un festival de
jazz
j'aimais bien considéré que mon café des
anges était une oeuvre d'art aussi un
sondage paru en 1991 dans télérama a
montré que le café des anges étaient le
lieu culturel préféré des strasbourgeois
de 15 25 ans et même très loin devant
tous les autres lieux
le commentaire de catherine trautmann
qui était à l'époque maire de strasbourg
et sera plus tard ministre de la culture
commencer par c'est un résultat étonnant
ah bah oui étonnant c'était le plus
petits lieux culturels de la ville
et en plus le seul non subventionnées
dans une ville richement dotée en
équipements culturels subventionner les
autres
un jour j'ai été contrôlé sans ceinture
de sécurité dans ma voiture
le policier qui m'a à contrôler quand il
a su que je travaillais au café des
anges
eh bien il m'a laissé partir en me
disant c'est bien ce que vous faites
mais mettez la ceinture quand même la
prochaine fois emballage était quand
même un petit peu fier là de d'apporter
ma contribution une contribution non
négligeable au bien-être à la qualité de
vie de ma ville et puis un jour un
ressort s'est cassé à strasbourg pour
des raisons que j'ai pas envie de vous
expliquer ici
alors après une traversée du désert
on a traversé la france avec femme
enfants baluchon on a traversé la france
on est venu s'installer à saint brieuc
en pauvre immigrée moi je me mets à
courir de plage en plage à marée basse
pour essayer de glaner un peu de pitance
marine après quelques séances de
vomissements familiale j'arrive à
distinguer la crépidule de la palourde
l'algue verte de la salicorne
et puis un jour en ramassant un vieux
journal là qui traînait pour me moucher
je vois un week end avec plein plein de
spectacles
je m'attendais pas à ce à quoi alors ça
a commencé à faire germer dans mon
esprit une idée une idée qu'elle est
sûrement me rapporter la fortune et la
gloire la création d'un magazine
d'information culturelle
elle y penser alors j'ai commencé à les
rencontrer un certain nombre d'acteurs
culturels du coin dont je tairai les
noms leur accueil a été carrément
encourageant on vit très bien sans ça
depuis des années que tu veux qu'on en
fasse on n'a pas besoin
si tu veux il se passe rien ici retourne
dans ton pays fois si tu veux pas qu'à
faire alors moi faut que je vous dise
que j'ai quand même une sale habitude
c'est que je fais jamais rarement ce qu
on me conseille de faire alors je
c'est à la réalisation de nos projets un
jour que je me promenais à la pointe du
roselier sublime point de vue sur la
baie de saint brieuc d'un coup là
j'entends un un coup de tonnerre des
éclairs et puis là une apparition de la
team dit le gris le long au journal tu
appelleras alors là moi je alors la bri
tombe à genoux la laine et la tête qui
ruisselle de pluie de pleurs et puis je
dis mais seigneur mais c'est
complètement idiot
oui bien sûr mais cette épreuve
supplémentaire dans durcira monfils
merci le [ __ ] bon alors alors je les
fais ce cri de l'ormeau ce magazine
d'information culturelle des côtes
d'armor
ça fait c'était en 1999 c'était au
siècle dernier
ça fait 17 ans et ça existe toujours
j'aime bien considérer aussi là que ce
cri de leurs mots c'est une oeuvre d'art
alors j'ai associé à ma démarche
quelques collaborateur collaboratrice
comme moi pas des journalistes pas des
commerciaux par des graphistes monde et
des hommes et des femmes de culture qui
connaisseurs en théâtre en musique en
culture bretonne en arts plastiques qui
ont eu envie de s'investir dans la même
direction que moi s'investir j'ai dit là
oui c'est le bon mot s'investir
d'ailleurs je proposerai qu'on ne parle
plus de dépenses culturelles mais
d'investissement culturel faut dire que
ce type d'investissement peut être
douloureux si vous saviez comme j'ai
galéré pendant des décennies enfin
pourquoi je vous raconte ma vie en fait
pour me faire mousser quoi avec mes 45
ans d'heures de vol dans le domaine de
la culture
45 ans d'investissement personnel dans
ça me permet aussi de me rappeler que je
suis plus tout jeune et ça fait chier
quoi
mais de quelle culture on parle
au départ la culture c'est travail de la
terre pour faire pousser des végétaux à
l'époque romaine cicéron 1 a donné
rajouter le mot annie mousse pour
transformer le sens à nîmes ou slam
c'était annie mac autorise culture de
l'âme jardin l'esprit quoi en 1982
l'unesco a proposé une définition de la
culture qui est l ensemble des traits
distinctifs spirituels et matériels
intellectuels et affectifs qui
caractérise une société ou un groupe
social se serrer pour se serrer la main
pour se dire bonjour c'est culturel
manger du poisson le vendredi portait un
pantalon re ou une robe ou une burqa
danser la gavotte tout ça c'est culturel
mais ce qui nous intéresse ici c'est une
définition plus restrictive de la
culture je veux dire l'ensemble des
activités artistiques humaines et des
biens et des services qui y sont liés
comme est d'aider les artistes
construire des équipements de spectacles
d'expositions des musées financer des
événements des manifestations favoriser
l'implantation d'industries culturelles
même là c'est
un évident de comprendre ce qu'on entend
par culturel on a en france une chaîne
de télévision qui s'appelle tf1 qui
passent des films des émissions de
variété des reality shows on l'appelle
pas chaîne culturelle alors qu'une autre
chaîne arte qui passent des films qui
font réfléchir dès des débats des de
l'art contemporain des documentaires
celle-là on l'appelle chaîne culturelle
c'est quoi la différence je vous
rappelle une déclaration du pdg de tf1
en 2004 qui disait je cite en gros
l'intérêt de nos émissions c'est de
rendre le cerveau humain disponible le
détendre le divertir pour le préparer à
la réception des messages publicitaires
fin de citation tf1 chaîne de
divertissement arte chaîne de culture
décervelage d'un côté gymnastique
cérébrale de l'autre ce que le cerveau
c'est comme un muscle il faut lui donner
de l'exercice
sinon c'est la nécrose mais en fait
à quoi ça sert la culture très bonne
question merci de me l'avoir posée et
bien les l'art et la culture ont des
incidences humaine et sociétal très fort
tout le monde le reconnaît
ça sert à favoriser la compréhension
humaine leu leu
le l'autonomie de l'individu c'est aussi
nécessaire que le ciment pour faire
tenir les briques d'un mur ou de l'eau
pour faire faire bouillir des hnwi sa
différence si l'homme de l'animal sa
différence si le bijou du caillou la
littérature du code pénal le la musique
du bruit quand je parlais de de soutenir
d'aider les artistes
je voulais parler aussi de favoriser
l'expression artistique de tout un
chacun de monsieur et madame tout le
monde parce que quand on permet à un
individu de s'exprimer ça va libérer de
certaines de ses frustrations
si un individu puis ça va me mettre en
valeur aussi auprès des autres et auprès
de auprès d'autres y auprès de lui même
si un individu entend ans entend traiter
à deux nuls à longueur de vie ou même
100 tentes réduit de rien du tout par
une société qui préfèrent ignorer son
existence alors l'individu là il va
peut-être mettre en oeuvre des choses
plutôt bizarre pour montrer qu'il existe
mais pas forcément pour se faire aimer
d'ailleurs l'artiste aussi est en cette
quête de l'estimé de soi mais lui il
agit d'où l'intérêt d'une action
culturelle qui va mettre en relation ces
artistes déclaré et le reste de la
population des jeunes en particulier des
études sérieuses ont montrés que
la pratique artistique et culturelle
était un très bon moyen de lutte contre
la maladie d'alzheimer ou la dépression
alors quand ça va pas fort là vous allez
chez un médecin l'a enfin docteur à pau
l'ag le projet pôle habitation pas la
frite
le docteur oui bah je vois bien ce qu'il
vous faut là alors vous me prendrez agen
3 pages de lecture
le soir après le repas une séance de
cinéma
et puis trois gouttes de chanson
française avant d'aller vous coucher
et puis vous écrire est un poème par
jour j'ai essayé et en plus la sécu m'a
remboursé alors on peut rêver est une
autre preuve de l'importance principal
est fondamental de l'art c'est que dans
le monde
les extrémismes et des fascismes ils ont
de cesse que de la détruire pour
empêcher les cerveaux de de penser et de
s'opposer à l'oppression ils détruisent
les interdisent la musique la presse les
images ils détruisent les oeuvres les
monuments pour dominer il faut tromper
et puis la culture louve les yeux alors
évidemment il n'aime pas ça
oui c'est bien beau tout ça mais euh ça
coûte quand même cher vous faut les
moyens pour ça oui mais ça peut
rapporter gros
prenez mon exemple avec 45 ans
d'investissements dans les cultures
maintenant je suis à la tête d'une
fortune colossale je suis à la tête
d'une entreprise de 2500 salariés qui
sont heureux qui me vénère kiki qui sont
qui pleurent de joie quand ils me voilà
aux commandes de mon hélicoptère qui va
au vernissage d'une expo d'art
contemporain dont je blague là je
déconne en fait le manière de la presse
que je suis là bas ça fait que à trois
quatre ans que j'arrive à toucher le
smic sur 17 ans à ba alors ça que tu
appelles les retombées économiques de
l'investissement culturel
bravo c'est vrai qu'à part des stars et
les institutions la plupart des artistes
quand même son avis dans la galère et la
souffrance y en a qui disent que ça les
rend plus fort que les chants les plus
beaux sont les plus désespérées
c'est dur pour eux mais c'est un choix
de vie alors qu'ils viennent pas nous
casser le moral avec eux leur mal de
vivre qui qu'ils en fassent de l'art de
leur mal de vivre
[Musique]
et puis il y en a qui auront aussi une
reconnaissance posthume
ça sera une consolation ses artistes
phares et
les traités de fainéants qui nous coûte
cher c'est décédé comme les imbéciles
mal comprenant les phares de l'humanité
et sens de bons retours et à l'âge des
cavernes derrière la liberté de
l'artiste ya la nôtre non le retombées
économiques de l'art et la culture c'est
pas sur l'individu qui les pratique
qu'elle porte c'est la société qui en
profite parce qu'un territoire de
culture il va bénéficier d'une
attractivité très forte
il va tirer des la population d
industrie d des consommateurs des
investisseurs il va vous créer des
profils commerciaux en france le secteur
culturel contribuer cette fois plus au
pib que l'industrie automobile
il ya le forum d'avignon qui est un
organisme qui étudie depuis une
trentaine d'années les relations entre
la culture et l'économie ont montré
qu'un accroissement de 10 % de dépenses
culturelles d'investissement culturel
provoque un accroissement de pib de 1,7
pour cent bon ça vous parle pas mais ça
veut dire que 18 euros de dépenses
culturelles que provoque un
accroissement de pib de 625 euros
bien sûr il ya d'autres facteurs
d'attractivité d'un territoire comme sa
beauté sa météo qui aidait toute
l'infrastructure dans tous les domaines
le sa gastronomie l'emploi mais la
culture apporte quand même ce complément
d'âme nécessaire à la qualité de la vie
au pays alors quand on vit dans un pays
pauvres défavorisés moche froid humide
il en existe heureusement pas en
bretagne
là il faut s'intéresser sérieusement
quand même au développement culturel
vous donner
exemple de retombées économiques de cet
investissement culturel
vous connaissez sûrement tous le l'effet
bilbao bilbao cette ville basque
espagnol qui était en plein marasme
économique pendant des années pendant
des générations
jusqu'à ce qu'en 97 l'ouverture du musée
guggenheim d'art contemporain
a fait exploser la ville la booster de
façon complètement incroyable plus près
plus récemment avec des incidences
qu'ont peut pas tout à fait mesurer le
vous avez le centre pompidou à metz le
louvre de lens
plus près d'ici la petite île de paimpol
vie mille habitants avec son festival
des chants de marins 11 millions d'euros
d'incidence économique encore plus près
binic 4000 habitants avec son folk blues
festival 2 millions d'euros de retombées
liverpool capitale européenne de la
culture en 2008 un milliard d'euros de
retombées aussi un peu le revers de la
médaille avec par exemple marseille
capitale européenne de la culture en
là bas ils ont détruit tout un quartier
populaire de la ville pour reléguer de
la population dans les ghettos des
quartiers nord et bétonner la ville à
leur profit ça s'appelle de la
gentrification ça est payant plus les
artistes au cours même pas été invité à
la fête la renault maintenant l'exemple
des côtes d'armor
nous vivons là c'est un pays qui était
anciennement pauvres qui a été enrichie
depuis des années des lustres par
l'élevage du porc qui est maintenant
dans une crise calamiteuse son industrie
principal et l'agroalimentaire et à côté
de ça y'a pas tellement d'industrie et
depuis quelques décennies les côtes
d'armor sont reçus devenu un pays un des
principaux pays de france pour l'art et
la culture c'est carrément devenu une de
ses plus grandes forces positives mais
ça se sait pas tant que ça d'où une
attractivité quand même modeste
sauf pour le tourisme alors suivant un
principe principes stratégiques du jeu
d'échecs qui consiste à renforcer ses
points forts plutôt que ses points
faibles
moi j'apporterai deux préconisations à
ce territoire un de développer encore
bien plus fortement son son
développement culturel son
investissement culturel et de de faire
en sorte que ça se sache dans le monde
entier parce que on peut avoir un
savoir-faire faut aussi le faire savoir
et puis jusqu'à ce qu'un jour on parle
plus de l'effet bilbao mais de l'effet
côtes d'armor ou alors mais on peut
aussi parler de l'effet montargis et de
l'éphémère montferrand données
saskatchewan et de l'effet et moselle
moselle vingt deux personnes bien deux
les faits
[Applaudissements]